introversion and extraversion a terms
first coined by psychiatrist Carl Gustav
Jung in Switzerland in the 1920s
according to Jung an extrovert seeks
intensive contact with the outside world
an introvert instead turns the psychic
energy inwards Jung believed that no one
is a hundred percent extrovert or a
hundred percent introvert instead we
carry both traits
however most minds tend to lean either
to one side or the other
if both characteristics are equally
present we can speak of someone who has
an ambivert personality in the 1960s the
psychologist hans eysenck added to Carl
Jung's ideas he argued that the main
difference between introverts and
extroverts lies in the way they gain and
recharge their mental energy by Nature
introverted people have a higher level
of brain activity and therefore feel a
greater need to shield themselves from
external stimuli by withdrawing
themselves they gain mental energy the
neuronal activity of extroverts is lower
they overcome this light by exposing
themselves to external stimulation this
charges their inner batteries to
illustrate the difference let's compare
two imaginary children jay is
extroverted he loves to be surrounded by
classmates he enjoys being the center of
attention and loves to talk to his
buddies about all kinds of stuff
he organizes football games with
strangers and right after is open to
playing ping-pong with someone else by
seeking social stimuli he gains mental
energy Ann is introverted as others play
around in the park she often enjoys
sitting alone watching at home she
plants herbs in the garden all by
herself she slowly becomes a real expert
in this field but that's her secret to
recharge her batteries and needs peace
and quiet time
introverts are not necessarily shy even
if it appears they like to walk away
from small talk and in fact is not shy
at all she is not afraid to talk to
anyone not even seniors when too many
people are around and the conversations
become superficial or confusing she gets
super tired her strategy is to fade out
and go inside herself to recharge
through silence Jay loves to have many
people around him to jump from one
conversation to the next stimulates him
some experts claim that extroverts and
introverts use different brain areas to
form their thoughts an extrovert tends
to use short term memory and therefore
is able to come to fast associations J
therefore talks fast and a lot he
appears smart because his brain always
offers an answer quickly
however he often speaks before he thinks
and later changes his mind
someone like Ann works with her brain to
carefully retrieve information from a
long-term memory her thoughts are more
complex and hence need more time to
develop she therefore thinks first and
then speaks if the two were asked for
directions by a tourist and would spend
time thinking about the best answer
while Jay would have already come up
with different kinds of options good
teachers and clever business leaders
know about the different nature of
introverts and extroverts and try to
develop their strengths when raising
questions they ask everyone to think for
a minute in silence before answering
extroverts then learn to formalize their
thoughts before they speak and
introverts get more talking time to
practice public speaking at
brainstorming they use a formal process
or a talking stick to make sure Ann Ann
also gets to participate
group projects can be formalized to
support both temperaments in one project
extroverts and introverts work together
Jay then learns from an how to think
ideas over to develop more complex
thoughts and in return benefits from
Jay's fast association skills and learns
to think and speak more flexibly in the
next project the same temperaments work
together then they see their own traits
in the opposite person if confronted
with problems in teams of the same
character introverts need to speak up
and extroverts are forced to think deep
to proceed the educator Rudolf Steiner
was a proponent of this method for his
waldorf schools psychologist Jerome
Kagan's research on temperament in
toddlers showed that many character
traits we are born with make it into
adulthood he confronted 500 babies with
different stimuli like loud sounds and
bad smells around 20% of the babies
cried or got nervous
40% stayed relaxed and the other 40%
were somewhere in between a second test
years later showed that babies who
didn't react strongly turned out to be
more extroverted what about yourself do
you consider yourself more introverted
or extroverted or do you think this
classification is flawed and there is no
such thing please share your thoughts in
the comments below
millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our sprouts videos
for better learning thousands of
teachers play them in their classrooms
to start projects volunteers on YouTube
have translated them to over 25
languages our mission is to promote
learning by doing in classrooms around
the world if you are a great explainer
and a passionate teacher and you want to
help us develop outstanding content
contact us to support our channel with a
donation visit patreon.com slash sprouts
you
[Music]
you